hey if you'd like to support the
production of more move university video
tutorials then please visit the support
move section on Luke universe comm thank
you and enjoy there's often this
question of what is good cholesterol but
it's bad cholesterol and that question
is actually answered here in the title
good cholesterol HDL is considered that
and LDL is considered bad cholesterol
but another common question I think is a
little bit more important is why is HDL
considered good cholesterol while LDL is
considered bad cholesterol it's an
important question investigate the first
and maybe obvious thing to point out is
that neither is actually cholesterol
right
they are lipoproteins cholesterol is
just a molecule shown here right there's
no good version there's no bad version
it's just a molecule two steroid
molecule shown here the second thing is
that neither is good or bad for you both
are important to normal physiology the
simple idea though when we think about
these things is that too much
cholesterol in cells can damage those
cells okay so basically if the amount of
cholesterol that we have exceeds the
need for for our cholesterol that's when
we're into some trouble okay so one
thing that we should be considering here
is to think about the key functions of
each LDL takes cholesterol to cells and
tissues HDL takes cholesterol from cells
and tissues so what's the normal
situation the normal scenario the normal
scenario is there's the right amount of
LDL taking cholesterol to cells and then
any slight excess is taken from the
cells by HDL back to the liver that's it
the end game is that you have the right
amount of cholesterol in your cells and
you have the right amount of cholesterol
in your blood the bad scenario what's
that look like
just ripple down a bit so in the bad
scenario we have too much LDL relative
to HDL taking cholesterol
two cells and these cells have a bunch
of cholesterol right and they don't need
more so what ends up happening is that
these cells don't want to take up any
more cholesterol from these LDL
particles so a bunch of LDL cholesterol
is left in the blood right so the low
relative levels of HDL cannot take
enough cholesterol from these cells back
to the liver so what ends up happening
is that we have too much LDL in the
blood so we have more oxidized LDL being
taken up our macrophages which increases
the amount of foam cells deposited in
the walls of the arteries which
increases plaque buildup and that causes
an obstruction of blood flow the tissues
can't give blood and then the tissues
can die which is obviously very bad
especially if we're talking about
vascular tissues especially in our the
ones that supply your heart brain so
really it's not about having LDL is bad
or having HDL is good it's about a ratio
and a proper balance between the two so
how is it that high LDL to HDL ratios
are prevented it's typically just dot a
proper diet and exercise and from what I
get from what I've read and heard is
that a good diet sort of helps to keep
up LDL levels lower whereas exercise
helped promote HDL synthesis so a proper
diet and exercise combined together will
give you a better healthier ratio so a
lower LDL to HDL ratio lower or equal to
3.5 is considered good because you have
the right amount of cholesterol on your
blood and cells whereas it being higher
than 3.5 is bad you have too much
cholesterol on your button cells which
of course is damaging so I hope that
kind of clears up that that question of
what's good and what's bad and why but
at the end of the day none of this is
medical advice
questions or concerns by your help
definitely until your physician I'm not
a healthcare professional and none of
this is medical advice hope that was
helpful thank you for watching thanks
for watching be sure to LIKE comment
subscribe and don't forget to share the
video of anyone who you think might find
it helpful thanks and happy studying